Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 15 of my 0 to 100 mil payto pay
flipping series. Today we are starting
about 17 mil. Now we're down to 14ish uh
cuz we just have to buy a bond actually
because our membership is about to
expire because again we are renewing our
membership only with money we earned uh
through bonds. Um anyway, yeah. So we're
starting about 17.7 mil. Um, and yeah,
I'm apologize this took so long to get
out, but uh hopefully we should be
releasing these a bit more frequently
now. And yeah, let's jump into it. Okay,
so I think we may actually flip these
emeralds. They have about a 100 GP
margin on more like 75 actually. Um,
which is pretty good for a freetoplay
item and this price. Uh, so we'll go
ahead and buy 4,000 or something. I
think that's the limit. Anyway, next up,
we can see uh quickly there, the myithal
war actually had an 8 GP margin, which
again uh is a free-to-play item is
pretty decent for the price. Uh so,
we'll go ahead and buy 13,000 of these,
I guess. Again, a full buying limits
worth. I would recommend the mythal ore.
I mean, I have already. Uh but yeah,
definitely works pretty well for freeto
play.
And last up here, I think we're going to
do the raw monkfish. Actually has a 12
GP margin in it. uh which is really good
actually for this item anyway. Uh so
we're going to go buy it for 436 and
we'll get probably like 8,000 or
something.
Uh not quite. We'll do like 7500 or
something or 7,000 is good. Okay, so
everything has sold. Uh we did pretty
decent on the mythore. Actually, we got
a 20 GP margin on that which is pretty
insane. Uh and 12,000 that gives us
about 240k profit from that. Uh the
emeralds we got 27 on each. Uh, but we
only got about 2.6k of those. Have a 75k
from that. Uh, the monk fish, we got a 9
GP margin, I guess. Yeah. And 7,000 monk
fish gives us about 63k. In total, we're
kind of looking at about 275k. That's
not too bad. Some steady progress.
Anyway, so because of how wor well that
worked, I think we're going to try the
myithal ore again. I getting like almost
250k from a item like this is pretty
insane. So, we'll go buy another 12,000
myth ore at 344 each. Um, so next up,
the gold amulet unrung has a 8GP margin
on it. Um, so we'll go ahead and try to
buy some of these. I think the buying
limit's actually like, yeah, we'll go
for 12,000 actually.
And next up, we'll do some Zver scales.
I think has a 4 GP margin on the Zolver
scales. So, we can do 20k of those
pretty easily. I think we can afford
that. Yeah, we should be fine. Um, but
yeah, getting about a 4 GP margin on
Zolver skill is actually really good
since they they flip so quickly. And
next up, the Cannonball has a 4GP margin
on it. And again, very frequently traded
item. Uh, we're going to try out some
more of these types of items soon, I
think. Um, but yeah, 5GP margin on this
is pretty nice. And I think the buy
limit is definitely over 10K. I'll have
to quickly check. Um, looks like it's
actually less. We're going to do 6K.
So, everything I have sold and we kind
of looked out in all of it because most
of it went up a little bit actually. Um,
if we start with um the item that made
us the least amount of money, let's see,
that would be the cannonballs, I guess.
Um, they had a 13 GP margin in them and
6,000 of those gave us 78k.
Uh, the Zer scales had a 4 GP margin and
30k of those gave us 120k.
And um the gold amulets had a 13 GP
margin in it actually. And they had
12,000 we managed to buy giving us about
156k from that which is pretty awesome.
The myithal organ managed to get 34 GP
margin on the myth or which is insane.
Um we only got about 3k of those given
us about 114k. So pretty nice when told
we probably got I don't know close to
300k. Um so again more steady progress.
Any of these items could be done by
anybody pretty well. all really popular,
but just happen to have pretty good
margins on them. Okay, so let's do some
new items. Okay, so I think we're going
to do the cannonballs again. They had
worked pretty well last time, so we'll
do 10,000 more cannonballs. Uh, so we
might do the Renar weed. I mean, only
has a 100 GP margin in it, but um should
trade pretty quickly. We're going to
look at it again. H yeah, I think we're
going to go for the grimy Renar cuz it
had a little bit of a better margin. And
uh I don't know, we'll probably buy a
thousand or something of these. We'll
use the rest of our money for the most
part. Um, but yeah, we'll have to see
how this works. The first time kind of
trying this item. So, the Renar actually
worked pretty well. Uh, even though we
only got about 1,500 of them. Um, that
still gave us about 180k in profit cuz
we got a 121 GP margin on that. Was
pretty expensive to buy all that, but
still pretty decent profit. And the
cannonballs we got nine each on and
10,000 of those gives us about 90k.
Um, and yeah, so not not too bad. Uh,
but we'll go try to get some other
items, I think. Okay, so the dragon axe
actually has a 7k marge on it, which is
pretty awesome. Uh, so we'll go ahead
and do that. Uh, 7,000 if we get the
full buying limits worth will be like
pretty good. That'll be like 5 600k if
we actually get the full amount. Um, so
hopefully we do. And yeah, we'll come
back when that has sold. Okay, so we are
back and we have managed to sell
everything pretty well. Uh the dragon
axes actually gave us a pretty good
profit. Um a little messy because we
sold them in two different chunks, but
in total we made 46k off of the dragon
axes, which is awesome. Uh the snap
dragons, we got 102 on each and 400 of
those gives us 40k only. Uh but the
cannonballs, we actually got nine on
each one and 14k of that gives us 120k
from cannonballs. So pretty decent. In
total, we probably got 600k or
something. Uh, which is pretty awesome.
Uh, the dragon axes have worked quite
well there. So, we might actually try
those again sometime. So, we just did a
quick calculation for crystal keys, and
it looks like we're actually going to
get more than 2k on each one if we
combine them right now. So, that's a
good opportunity to go buy them cuz for
every 100 keys I make, that's 200k. Uh,
which is pretty sweet. So, we'll go
ahead and probably buy pretty much our
entire cash stack worth of the component
pieces.
Um, yeah, we'll get maybe a little more
than 300. Maybe. I don't know. Maybe we
can only afford 300, but we'll have to
double check this. Okay, it looks like
we're actually going to do 400. Uh,
looks like we can afford it. Yeah, 400
of each should be good. And, uh,
assuming all goes well, that should be
800k. Okay, so we are back and, uh, we
managed to combine 300 keys. Uh, not
quite 400, but that's still the
majority, which is nice. And we still
made a I think we still got about a 2k
margin actually because we got about
581k from the keys. You can see me kind
of calculating it in the background and
we got 300 keys. So that would kind of
add up. Uh so 500ks from the crystal
keys brings us to about 17.2
mil or something. Eventually I do claim
all these items but um yeah 17.2 2 mil.
And um while we did start at about 17.7
mil, so there's a 500k loss technically
right now, but we did buy a bond for 3
mil. So throughout the episode, I think
we made actually between two and 3 mil,
probably like 2.5 roughly. Uh which is
pretty good considering none of these
items were kind of like outstanding.
They're just like a big compilation of
decent items that you could flip over
and over again. Anyone could really do.
So, it's kind of nice to see they can
make progress even with kind of normal
items. Um, yeah, I think that's where
we're going to call it for today, guys.
I hope you enjoyed and uh we'll see you
in episode 16.
[Music]